in this lesson we're going to talk about
volume of cylinders so
usually when they give these type of
problems on the act they'll give you the
formula for the volume of a cylinder but
it's good just to know how to work with
the formula and understand what it
represents and and so on so let's just
kind of go through this real quick here
a cylinder basically is like a a can
like a can of pop or soda like that and
the volume v is equal to pi which of
course is the 3.14 times the radius
squared times the height okay so the
height is the distance between the two
circles the two circular bases and the
radius is the
distance from the center to a point on
that circle there so let's go through an
example see if you can do this one on
your own and we'll go through it
together it says if the volume of a
cylinder is 200 cubic centimeters and
the height is 10 centimeters what is the
radius of the base so see if you can do
that one on your own and we'll go
through it together here so we've got
volume equals pi r squared h i usually
like to write the formula down first and
then substitute in what you know so 200
equals pi
times r squared times the height which
is 10. so i'm just going to work from
the outside in towards uh towards r so
i'm going to divide both sides by pi
and 10
okay so i'll just say 10 pi so that way
those cancel and so now we're down to
let's see let's reduce this a little bit
so 10 goes in here 20 times so we have
20 divided by pi
equals r squared and then if we take the
square root because we're trying to
cancel that out we want to do that to
both sides so the radius is the square
root of 20 over pi that's an exact
answer
you could do it on your calculator and
get a decimal approximation but i
basically just wanted to make sure that
you're familiar with the volume of
cylinders this problem you know they
have something with a cylinder on the
test in some form generally and so again
it's just good to know the formula and
how to work with it